hey Evie how does it feel to be the
fairest of them all wait what are you
saying that you don't care about that
stuff anymore your mother would be
ashamed of you
but that's not necessarily a bad thing
you might not care about being the
prettiest girl in the room anymore but
you definitely care about being the most
fashionable one and well there's nothing
wrong with that it's hard to imagine a
world where Sophia Carson isn't plain
Evie just like her character there's so
much more to this celebrity than meets
the eye we've got twenty fun facts about
Sophia coming their way so don't go
anywhere she signed to BMI records to
say that Sophia Carson has a beautiful
voice would be an understatement
she blew us away with her performance in
descendants and she's not done with Evie
just yet I was lucky enough to have been
given a chance did you know that Sophia
is signed to BMI records as a pop and
Latin artist we can't say were surprised
she's friends with some pretty famous
people Sophia is known for her awesome
personality and star quality you go girl
I mean um Queen so she's got more than a
few famous contacts amongst her friends
list she's friends with fifth harmony
and Becky gee she was bullied in high
school it's hard to believe that Sophia
Carson hasn't been popular since the day
she was born but in reality
Sophia was bullied so much in high
school that she switched schools
thankfully Sophia's second high school
experience turned out to be a lot better
than the first one despite all of this
Sophia says that changing schools was
the best thing that ever happened to her
she's trilingual Sophia's a
jack-of-all-trades she can sing dance
act and more unsurprisingly she also
happens to be trilingual she's mastered
Spanish English and French we wonder if
she and Deb Cameron ever speak French to
each other on the set of descendants she
was born to be a star
Sophia started taking dance lessons when
she was only three years old and by the
time she was seven years old she was
playing Dorothy in the Miami theater
production of The Wizard of Oz at 22
years old Sophia landed her first ever
role as he be from descendants my mom's
Queen which makes me a princess she's a
total fangirl
where would the world of entertainment
be without fangirls nowhere and Sophia
can attest to that because well she's a
major fangirl herself
Sophia's person of choice is none other
than Ross Lynch the stars first met on
the set of Austin and Ally
she's Colombian Sophia's parents were
born in Colombia but they moved to
America before Sophia was born I'm so
thankful to my parents her mother's
family is related to the charr family
who happened to be a renowned family of
Colombian politicians she shares her
birthday with Shay Mitchell
Sofia Carson was born on April 10th 1993
and she just so happens to share her
birthday with Shay Mitchell who plays
Emily fields in Pretty Little Liars
Mandy Moore who voices Disney's Rapunzel
is also born on April 10th so if this is
your birthday too you might have what it
takes to be a star she uses her
grandmother's last name Sophia's real
name is Sophia two carat char but for
personal reasons
she chose to forego her given name and
use her grandmother's last name instead
it isn't uncommon for celebrities to use
stage names and Sophia Carson totally
has a ring to it
she's single and loving it Sophia might
very well be the fairest of them all but
when it comes to relationships she isn't
one to jump ship Sophia is currently
single and loving it she's focusing on
her career and reaping the benefits it
has been such a whirlwind to be a part
of this franchise if she's seen someone
it's a total secret she's super close
friends with Sabrina carpenter Sophia
met her close friends Sabrina carpenter
on the set of further adventures in
babysitting hi I'm and the girls have
been inseparable ever since
she stars on the perfectionist if you're
sad for The Descendants franchise is
coming to an end don't be because Sophia
Carson isn't done with the small screen
just yet she plays Ava Jalali on the
Pretty Little Liars spin-off the
perfectionists
leave me and my friends alone and just
let this come she grew up in Florida
Sophia's roots may be Columbian but
she's a first generation American
Sophia was born in Fort Lauderdale
Florida where she spent the majority of
her life the actress moved to California
to attend UCLA after graduating high
school
she's a Bruin Sophia's been trying to
complete her studies for a while now but
due to her successful acting and singing
career she's had to put her degree on
the back burner according to the actress
I'm technically still a Bruin but I'm
going to graduate maybe when I'm 45
she's a fashion runway star just like
her own screen character Evie sophia is
obsessed with fashion you never see her
in a basic outfit and she always shows
up for Paris Fashion Week she even
walked in several shows herself Sophia
and Game of Thrones actress Maisie
Williams both attended the Stella
McCartney fall winter fashion show in
2019 and they even sat next to each
other she's a lot like Evie in real life
being a part of the descendence cast
really had an effect on Sophia's
wardrobe
she loves wearing leather and is often
seen sporting gorgeous leather jackets
Evie would definitely approve of her
look you know I'm right she's been
writing songs since she was a kid
Sophia has wanted to become a singer
since she was just a kid so we're not
surprised that the actress has been
writing lyrics since she was 10 years
old according to Sophia she once wrote a
heartbreaking song when she was just a
preteen she sees Cameron Boyce as her
little brother descendants fans would
love it if Evie and Carlos got together
and we can't fake it
but in reality the actors are so close
they might as well be family in fact
Sophia considers Cameron voice as her
not so little little brother Sophia is
in a Shawn Mendes music video Shawn
Mendes is a brilliant artist so we're
not surprised that he had Sophia Carson
and dove Cameron star in his music video
believe she's a total role model Sophia
loves to encourage young girls to be
themselves and she makes sure to always
be on her best behavior to promote
happiness self-worth and intelligence
she takes pride in being the role model
young girls deserve to be the fairest of
them all it doesn't mean that
find by your reflection in the marriage
who you are in your heart is Sophia
Carson your role model let us know in
the comment section below and that's a
wrap thanks for tuning into the things
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe for more fun
videos like this one we'll see you next
time
[Music]